[Music]
there's a huge spider
back in october kim kardashian jetted
off to a private island on a private jet
with her family and friends in tow
to celebrate her 40th birthday it's been
so much fun
now she's giving fans an inside look at
her epic
and i mean epic getaway
[Music]
on thursday the keeping up with the
kardashians star shared her birthday
vlog
on instagram and let's just say we
laughed we cried
we felt all the feels
[Music]
the whole crew who kim says were all
coveted
before boarding the pj i swear hung out
at the pool
and if you look closely right there
there's a rare sighting of kim's younger
brother
rob kardashian okay
i'm gonna show you another i guess they
had a chicken fight
[Music]
ah yes remember people and places and
social gatherings
[Music]
anyway all right so we are whale
watching we're not
whip watching we're about
they're watching this whale with
humpback whales
to go swimming in the ocean like this is
next level right here we're getting in
the water with homes it's like a once in
a lifetime once in a while
my heart is weak the birthday girl her
pal lala
anthony her little sister kendall jenner
and rob
all went swimming with freaking whales
okay
so we are in the water the whale is
right over there
the candle is tripping
i have to pee so badly and i want to but
i'm so afraid the whale is going to
smell
one sibling noticeably missing chloe
chloe would die yeah if you keep up with
the kardashians you know
whales are coco's biggest fear just like
whales
for you oh stop it
who the even go and approach a big whale
then kimberly hit us with some deep
thoughts because
you know she's 40 now and she's a
grown-ass adult
it's just crazy to know that we could be
right in here and there could possibly
be a shark
like we just will never know oh and
this hot tip and remember guys if a
shark comes i saw this on shark week
punch it in the nose and in the eyes but
the daytime whale adventure had
nothing on the nighttime dance party i
just don't dance
okay i make money moves yeah even kim
danced
[Music]
with the help of a little liquid courage
of course
kanye west also danced to
well kanye west
[Music]
[Applause]
mama kris jenner worked that leopard
print caftan like a pro
[Music]
tristan thompson hopped around
courtney danced with um
umbrellas
but chris's longtime boyfriend corey
gamble dropped the mic
on all of them
[Music]
he just swung his leg around and
casually landed in a split guys
ouch yeah just pop up on the pop-up
but perhaps the sweetest moment of the
vlog came courtesy of
kanye who gifted his wife with a
hologram of her late dad
robert kardashian happy birthday
kimberly
look at you you're 40 and all grown up
and while kim had previously shared
clips of the over-the-top gesture on
social media
in her vlog fans got to see the
emotional moment after she and her
sisters chloe and courtney
watched it for the first time keep doing
what you're doing kimberly
you are a beautiful soul know that i am
very proud of you
and i'm always with you i love you
kimberly
thank you for that
seriously thank you
can we see it again
you